à 10 km de tours le site de la
paternelle à mettrais une commune dont
le nom reste lié à jamais à sa colonie
une institution pour jeunes délinquants
du milieu du 19e siècle
jean michel six plus qu'un avocat durant
40 ans barreau de tours s'est plongée
dans l'histoire de cette colonie
agricole et pénitentiaire depuis sa
création en 1839 par un avocat humaniste
frederic auguste de m avant bien les 139
les mineurs délinquants sont condamnés
par les tribunaux correctionnels et
pourrissent dans les prisons mélanger
aux majeurs dans des conditions
d'insalubrité absolue est de mettre le
fondateur de la colonie à cette idée
l'agriculture est très forte à l'époque
donc il emprunte à charles lucas
inspecteurs des prisons la formule
sauver la terre par l'écolo et les
colons par la terre inspirée d'un modèle
prussiens cette colonie est une première
en france
admirez en europe pas de murs ni de
barreaux avec son ami le vicomte de
bretenières de courteille frédéric de
médecins font d'une colonie qui n'a rien
d'une prison c'est d'appel blue et grand
prix de rome a kiss in architecture
originale d'un village cinq maisons de
colons qui comprendront cinq familles
c'est la notion de famille qui est
présente il y en a 5 à droite y en a 5 à
gauche il y en avait cinq à gauche et on
va regrouper tout ça autour de l'église
et la grand place principale où il y
avait des réunions notamment le dimanche
et puis les ateliers tout autour de m à
cette idée géniale de dire moi je veux
pas faire garder ses gosses par des
gardes-chiourmes je veux former des
professionnels et il va créer ici ce qui
va être la première école d'éducateurs
en france
ce qu'il appelle l'école des
contremaîtres et ils deviennent chefs de
famille dans une maison commises comme
devant nous
chef d'atelier vous chef de ferme
d'ailleurs aussi dans l'est dans les
fermes sur lesquels ces gamins vont
travailler
avec la collaboration des archives
départementales et de deux historiens
jean michel cyclus qui veut rétablir la
vérité historique de la colonie ne
mettrai les 40 premières années dans la
lumière et la période noire de son
histoire entre deux guerres avec le
colon le plus célèbre jean genet qui
écrira en 1946 miracle de la rose
une évocation des deux années et demie
passées à la colonie les tourangeaux ont
gardé ceux qui se souviennent ont gardé
cette image très noir dubai d'enfants de
la chasse à l'enfant savez quand il y
avait des évasions les premières
quarante années il n'y a pas eu
d'évasion et puis dans les dernières
années c'était tous les deux jours
ça c'est dans la période noire c'est un
surveillant qui s'appelait guespin qui
est décorée et dont on sait qu'il est à
l'origine de morts d'enfants
il a été dénoncé et nommé par alexis dan
en commun d un des assassins de mettray
alexis danan est un grand reporter un
peu comme albert londres à l'époque et
qui prend en bille en tête
sebag d'enfants et notamment et
notamment mettrait avait près un siècle
d'existence la colonie mettrais fermera
ses portes en 1937
aujourd'hui jean michel cyclus qui est
l'association la paternelle organise
expositions et conférences pour faire
revivre cette histoire ancrée dans la
mémoire tourangelle avec ses parts
d'ombrés et de lumières